hello neighbor
hey I'll do it I like the year mr.
Rogers like Matthew McConaughey sir I'm
in my neighbor over hey I like where you
know they okay I like puppets I did not
really grow up on mr. Rogers I'm sorry
I've seen a lot of spoofs of him you did
though I did yeah Rogers you're like a
70s kid or something yeah let's see what
is this video that people have asked us
to check out and I saw its number uno on
the threatening and ending si mr. Rogers
man and do the exact opposite you have
mr. Rogers neighborhood low production
values simple sex unlikely star yet it
worked
[Music]
he's always trying to get a message
across and every show a week on that is
assassination means what it works some
people get married and after a while
they're so unhappy that they don't want
to be married anymore
he was radical I know he was rather like
people to come and swim in their funny
pools by being on the program was a
statement for Fred
my neighborhood was a place where at
times that you felt worried scared
unsafe would take care of me
[Music]
he had a single vision and paces in love
I visit the root of everything all
learning all relationships not for the
lack of it
she won't have very deep feelings just
the way everybody does
[Music]
right now that
[Music]
the person said invitation it's an
invitation for somebody because to
[Music]
the greatest thing that we can do is to
help somebody know that they're loved
and capable of
oh that warmed my heart up but good I
feel like nowadays especially just like
with the world the way it is I feel like
we could use a little mr. Rogers at the
moment a little a little kindness and
love from a genuine place but the way
the world is John the world's always
been crap we as always need mr. Rogers
true it's so cool to see one of these
like historical like peace documentaries
and interviews of people who were around
during this time for some people who
appeared on mr. Rogers I feel like nine
point nine times out of ten when I see
some documentary about like the 60s or
the 70s it's always like the political
dark times in the world and this was
something that was just about love and
kindness and embrace it's honing in on
the themes and mr. Rogers exploiting
money out of the show on PBS about
showing the cultural impact and we don't
have anyone like him right now not at
the moment
except for Tyrone Magnus oh yeah I mean
Tyrone is probably the closest we're
gonna get to mr. Rogers in our life yeah
this looks delightful this feels very
insightful and it feels like inspiring a
lot of times you know I feel like the
word inspiring can be thrown around a
little loosely and it also depends on
the context what you're using it in
sometimes the thing that motivates me
more than anything else is acts of
kindness acts of love there's a
documentary series that my girlfriend
show me called the kindness Diaries on
Netflix and it's all about doing kind
deeds and it sounds like it'd be dull
like there's no complicated not wants to
be nice and this reminds me of that what
I loved about seeing this was he was
doing rather social political movements
like featuring those black people in the
pool it's a big statement to make and at
that time like he was doing things that
people like she'd be doing this on
television we should be talking about
this to kids on television but he did it
anyway it's
so yeah definitely and that was some of
the stuff in this trailer that was a bit
new or enlightening to me is the strides
he took for social issues and one yeah
you know the the way he used his
platform to help people out you know
especially during rough times for civil
rights and like that's super important
and that's something that you know we
can often forget the kindness not always
as simple as we think it is sometimes
it's about making a larger Aegeus yeah
definitely definitely I mean he taught
me what polyamorous relationships are
mr. Rogers Weiss what is that sometimes
you want to make love to more than one
person at a time
I call that Avinash approaching the
difficult issues in in a way I also just
love his respect for children too
because I have a hard time connecting
with kids just you know the way it seems
like a problem really was yeah well
nowadays especially keeps everything on
a really even keel don't have to worry
about anybody misinterpreting anything
but yeah you know just the way he seemed
to be able to understand and identify
with you know young people young minds
and whatnot and you know to interact in
a wholly wholesome way is also inspiring
you know speaking of inspiring inspiring
I think we should give a shout out today
for patreon to erica Tuesday Oh what's
up Erica Jon I know Eric has been quite
an inspiration in your life once you
take this one
hey man I'm me and Erica is one of the
most kind-hearted and warm people I know
she's always opening up her place to her
friends and even to people she doesn't
know very well she's very hospitable
very thoughtful and just a terrific
artist to all around in her own way
works with the kids working on those
cartoons and whatnot she's an
illustrator by day and then she does her
own artistic pursuits by night and
loving and accepting you know just a
kind kind-hearted soul the past few
times you have gone over to one of her
get-togethers and she's invited me along
and I have I think the next time you
extend that invite I'm gonna do my best
to show up no matter what
very good so thank you for being here my
dear you're really kind-hearted so
anyway guys who in your life is like a
Mister Rogers
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification
to get notified when a video of ours is
up and you can check us out on patreon
we do weekly Q&A is we take a question
to a full video response to it and we
also do full-length TV show reactions
over there plenty of shows recovering
right now would love to have you join us